>> Laura: THIS MEMORIAL DAY WE
TAKE THE TIME TO HONOR THOSE WHO
GAVE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE AND
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE.
TONIGHT, WE WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO SARAH GERARDO,
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
NONPROFIT ASSISTING SEVERELY
WOUNDED VETERANS AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS AND SHE IS ALSO A
CAREGIVER TO HER HUSBAND,
MICHAEL, ONE OF THE MOST
SEVERELY WOUNDED VETERANS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HE'S NOW UNDERGOING HIS 119
SURGERY.
SARAH, WELCOME TO THE ANGLE.
FIRST OF ALL, I HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO YOU ON THE RADIO, YOU
ARE SO INSPIRING.
YOUR HUSBAND HAS SUFFERED
GREATLY.
HE HAS BEEN THROUGH MORE
SURGERIES THAN ANYONE CAN BEAR
AND REMEMBER.
BUT YOU HAVE TURNED YOUR FOCUS
NOT JUST TO TAKE CARE OF HIM BUT
ALSO TO HELP RAISE MONEY FOR
THESE TRACK CHAIRS AND OTHER
ITEMS AND DEVICES THAT OUR
VETERANS NEED THAT THE VA
BENEFITS DON'T NECESSARILY
COVER.
>> I REALIZE THAT WHEN MICHAEL
MINE BEGAN.
MINE WAS FOUGHT ON THE HOMEFRONT
OF THE VERY INSTITUTION THAT I
THOUGHT WOULD TAKE CARE OF HIM,
THE VA.
IT'S A VERY BUREAUCRATIC AND
LONG PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT I
LOVE ABOUT THIS.
IF WE SEE AN UNMET NEED A
COMPLETE GO FILL IT WITH A TRACK
WHEELCHAIRS OR ANYTHING ELSE
THESE HEROES NEED TO.
>> Laura: SO INDEPENDENCE
FUN.ORG.
THANK YOU GUYS HAVE RAISED
$60 MILLION, BILL O'REILLY HAS
HELPED RAISE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
YOUR HUSBAND LOST HIS LEG AND
MOST OF ONE ARM, CORRECT?
YOU HAVE THREE YOUNG DAUGHTERS.
HOW IS LIFE TODAY?
>> WE FEEL VERY BLESSED.
AS WE GO INTO MEMORIAL WE
WEEKEND, MANY OF MY DEAREST
FRIENDS ARE WIDOWS AND THEY HAVE
AMERICAN FLAGS AND PLACE OF
THEIR HUSBANDS.
OUR LIFE IS MUCH MORE
CHALLENGING THAN I HAD EVER
PREDICTED AS I STARTED THIS
JOURNEY WITH MICHAEL BUT OUR
BLESSINGS HAVE OUTWEIGHED THAT.
WE ARE VERY LUCKY.
BUT FOR THE WANTED TO COME UP
THE FIGHT NEVER ENDS AND WE ARE
WITH THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
>> Laura: THE VA EMISSION ACT,
I BET YOU WILL BE ON BOARD AND
THE PRESIDENT SIGNS THAT IN
EARLY JUNE.
THAT WILL DO A LOT TO HELP OUR
VETERANS.
THIS PRESIDENT GETS VERY LITTLE
CREDIT FROM THE MEDIA, BUT THIS
IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
A LOT MORE MONEY WILL GO TOWARD
REHABILITATION AND HELPING THOSE
IN NEED.
>> MY HUSBAND, WE HAVE HAD A LOT
OF TIME TO SPEND THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS FAMILY AND HE
HAS AN UNMATCHED HEART FOR
VETERANS.
HE CAMPAIGNED UNEQUIVOCALLY THAT
VETERANS BE ABLE TO CHOOSE HIS
OR HER OWN HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
AND ITS PROMISE MADE TO COME UP
FROM HIS ACADEMIC CAPS.
WE ARE THRILLED.
>> Laura: THE NEWS WHEN YOU
GOT IT, APRIL 24, 2010.
TAKE US BACK TO THAT DAY.
>> WE WEREN'T MARRIED AT THE
TIME SO I GOT IT FROM HIS
MOTHER.
WE WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL TOGETHER,
DURING THE EVENTS OF
SEPTEMBER 11, DEFENDANTS FOR HIS
CALL TO ACTION.
SO I WAS NOT SURPRISED TO LEARN
THAT WHEN MICHAEL DOES SOMETHING
HE GOES ALL IN, ALL THE WAY.
HE WAS SO PROUD AND HE WOULD GO
BACK TOMORROW IF THEY WOULD LET
HIM.
>> Laura: 82ND AIRBORNE.
GOING BACK TO KANDAHAR, LIKE SO
MANY OF OUR BRAVEST, STEPPED ON
AN IED THAT WAS PLANTED.
HORRIFIC, VICIOUS THINGS.
I WILL SEE YOU AT WALTER REED
NEXT WEEK I HOPE AND GET A
CHANCE TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH
HIM.
IndependenceFund.org, AN